[Music]
good evening thank you for coming
I'm Stuart bran from the long now
foundation I should say that you know
most of you have these question cards
and in the semi-darkness of the theater
it's helpful when you've written out a
question to come up to the front for
Kevin Kelly and me to look at you later
address the speaker with it's helpful if
you waive it so that the guys in the
yellow hats can see it come collect it
bring it up and you know write questions
anytime during the talk during the Q&A
that's the interactive part now the long
now foundation is called the long now
because we have in mind the next 10,000
years in the last 10,000 years and Peter
Schwartz here is the one who came up
with that number because 10,000 years
ago there was a biotech revolution
having to do with mainly plants and then
animals that we eat and use we started
genetic modification genetic engineering
in a big way and humanity took a swerve
that is still getting used to about a
hundred and fifty years another biotech
revolution happened with biomedicine and
humans started to be able to control
their health be able to control their
birthrate and then we get to the 21st
century which is regarded by many as the
century of biology which the large
extent means this entry of biotechnology
and so these revolutions that we've seen
seem to be on a kind of biotech Moore's
Law of getting more and more frequent
and happening now in one lifetime
instead of it millennia at a time and
the current acceleration of genetic
science and genetic engineering is often
the case being carried by very sharp
individuals scientists who find the
right problems find the right people to
work with
the right funding and Swarm ahead and
really the exemplary case of that these
days is craig Venter
please welcome in well thank you story
that's certainly nice to be here with
the long now foundation taking a a long
view
hopefully forward with with humankind I
think it's very much an open question
but what we're trying to see if we can
change some of the equations maybe to
help that process along I can talk about
two different phases of information
tonight the first phase is gathering the
information actually refer to it and in
my case is reading the genetic code and
then I'll turn to how now we're using
that information to change evolution to
change biology to change hopefully some
parts of society with writing the
genetic code and I'll talk about the
early steps of that all this has
happened in a pretty short period of
time we sequenced the first genome of a
living species hemolysis influenza in
1995 before then we developed techniques
for scaling up gene discovery but we've
only had complete genomes of living
organisms for a relatively short period
of time it's changing our view of
looking at biology we did two genomes in
1995 and I'll talk about the second one
and the later phases of this had very
different sized genomes very different
characteristics but after those first
two that we had to fund ourselves we
started getting a lot of government
funding to scale up the process we got
funding to do almost every major human
pathogen we moved into plants than
simple animals than more complex ones
such as fruit flies and people the big
change in technology after 1995 came
surprisingly only four to five years
later with a fruit fly genome lamothe
less was 1.8 million letters of genetic
code Drosophila is 180 million and they
were both done in the same four months a
time period and nine months later we had
the 3 billion letter first draft of the
human genome computational aspects were
very important we actually had to build
the third largest computer in the world
to do this calculation now it's not so
hard to do with much more standard
computers one and a half ter ops and
1999 was a huge computer today we have
things ten twenty thirty and a hundred
times that at size just this last year
we published the first complete human
genome
this was the diploid genome so it had
both sets of chromosomes from from both
parents what was done in 2000-2001 ended
up being only half the job the public
effort only got it half right because
they set out to only do half thinking
the other half would be easily
discernible the project that salera
actually tried to do the complete genome
but we made the mistake of overreaching
we tried to do the genome of five
individuals it was three women three men
and two women that was three women and
two men
sounds like a San Francisco movie
but because of the diversity when when
we assembled the genome we we ended up
subtracting out all the major variation
between them so the message and many of
you will remember at 2000-2001 is we all
have the same set of genes and we all
differ from each other only in one out
of a thousand letters of genetic code
and this started all kinds of people
down certain tracks we have a pretty
large industry now just to measure those
one out of thousand differences but it
turns out we're all one to three percent
different from each other
so it's a much greater variation than we
imagined to put that in context we
thought we differ from chimpanzees only
by one point two seven percent so you're
probably hoping that number changed as
well or we really have some explaining
to do about evolution it turns out we're
four to five percent different from
chimps and so this this individual
variation was totally missed the two
sets of chromosomes that each of you
have each of those sets of chromosomes
they don't necessarily have the same
gene that the other pair has for example
there's a major gene associated with
detoxifying environmental toxins that of
the Caucasian population a third I have
no copies of this gene another third
have one copy in another third have two
copies but even when you have two copies
there's major variation of these so it's
hard to find two of us with the exact
same genetic code and we have a lot of
complexity I think it's important that
we know it now because it means we can
move towards getting the right answers
in this first genome almost half the
genes had a major variant in them
and this certainly is going to confound
anybody who was hoping to get simple
interpretations out of the human genetic
code so we we have all kinds of
companies promising that now for $1,000
but it's only a partial peek at what
might be there 75% of the letters of
genetic code their variant between any
two of us didn't show up in the single
nucleotide polymorphisms that people
were measuring
so we're scaley not now to do 10,000
human genomes over the next decade
hopefully it won't take 10,000 years
Stewart but maybe only 10 and we will
finally have the first chance to
understand what's genetic what's nature
and what's nurture not only with the
genetic code but we're trying to collect
intense extensive phenotypic information
on all these individuals that we're
going to be sequencing and that's a much
greater challenge when you think about
all the information that might describe
you where your lives how you look how
you think your body structure your organ
structure your metabolism all those
things differ dramatically with each of
us and trying to describe that makes
sequencing the genome look like the easy
part
we've published our data in the public
access of journal of biology you can
download this 300 megabyte file if you
want to it's a it's a zoomable version
of the human genome that shows the types
and and extent of human variation and
hopefully in a short time you'll be able
to get the map of your genome this way
working with the XPrize foundation we
now have a 10 million dollar prize for
whoever gets the technology going to the
extent that we can sequence an
individual genome for $1,000 in a very
short period of time so we're hopeful
that we'll be giving out that ten
million dollars in the next five years
looking for a little spare change you
might try inventing something worthwhile
we're releasing a new browser for the
genome that allows it to be looked at
down to the the sequence file level as
people for example get data from 23andme
or other places they can look at
actually a complete genome to try and
put it in some kind of context and find
out how much is missing from those early
tests now when we finished sequencing
the human genome many people were hoping
that would retire but instead we looked
around for what we thought were the most
important projects in science to do
particularly with what the technology
that we developed for reading the
genetic code could try and tackle and it
was clear to us that trying to look at
the environment not only the extensive
environment around us that helps
influence our genes but the broader
environment to see if we could use DNA
sequence as the new tool to see who we
were sharing the planet with there's
been this statistic for a long time that
each milliliter of seawater has a
million bacteria in ten million viruses
but nobody really knew what that meant
and whether there was any diversity in
that and so we decided to do an
experiment in the Sargasso Sea just
taking a barrel of seawater filtering
out all the organisms in it isolated in
the DNA from them on mass and sequencing
it and just from one barrel of water we
stopped sequencing after we had close to
1.4 million new genes maybe it's 40,000
new species that had never been seen
before so the technique obviously worked
because in fact people thought we'd find
little or no life in their Sargasso Sea
because it was supposed to be a desert
with no nutrients in it and I'll show
you why and how these organisms survived
and emitted but we decided to look
further and we started the source or
to expedition I had always been looking
for an excuse to sail around the world
on my own vessel and so we decided we
would follow great scientific
expeditions such as the Challenger
expedition and sail around the world
taking samples every 200 miles and
sequencing everything we could find to
see if we could generate a different
view of life and we were absolutely
stunned with what we found and that was
a special issue of PLoS that was
published last year this is the route
that we followed as with the Challenger
expedition we started in halifax went
down the eastern seaboard into the
caribbean sea then down between Mexico
and Cuba to the Panama Canal through the
Panama Canal and down to first Cocos
Island and then to the Galapagos and and
that's the dot you see here in blue
that's what was covered in the special
issue of PLoS of biology and that
covered over 6 million new genes more
than doubling the number of genes known
from all science up to that point and
we've now been analyzing the samples
from the rest of the globe after
Galapagos we left and sailed that the
mark eazy-e's where we are promptly
arrested because there was a debate
between the French government and the
French Polynesia government as who had
rights over the microbes that are there
and you may not understand this but this
is this is a physical map if you look at
a political map in the Caribbean Sea for
example there's no international waters
every drop of water is claimed by one or
more countries and you need permission
from them to take a scientific sample
they're there it's okay to fish and most
of those places you can you know shoot
marine mammals you can do whatever you
want but if you're asking scientific
questions it's considered extremely
dangerous and you can get arrested for
it and in fact when
the organisms and the ocean are out in
the middle of the Pacific Ocean they're
in international waters and they belong
to nobody or to everybody as soon as the
one not current that goes across the
Pacific carries them into French
Polynesia all those microbes instantly
become French genetic heritage and in
they're willing to defend it to the
extreme we finally got out of there and
took samples and spent some time in
Australia then went across the Indian
Ocean we got halfway across and we
stopped and shaco's Island which is near
where our country has a b-52 airbase and
we were rusted again by the British this
time because they were worried we would
take samples and understand science and
that water so sunny it's just something
and organisms that are greatly protected
around the world and to be able to
publish this data in the public
databases we had to put Geographic GPS
coordinates on every DNA sequence so for
example if somebody makes a discovery
using the sequences that we found in
Australia and you want to commercialize
those you have to contact the Australian
government and negotiate something
that's not clear what so science is it's
much more complicated today but the the
experiments were very simple we just
simply filtered seawater through
different sized filters we could then
just take those filters put them in the
freezer when we got into a port we put
them in a FedEx package with some dry
ice and sending them back to the lab and
in Rockville Maryland where all the DNA
was isolated at once from them and
sequenced and then reconstructed in the
computer and when we reconstructed it we
are amazed with what we found for
example every 200 miles 85% of the
sequences and the organisms are unique
the oceans not a giant home
genius mixture samples that we've taken
off of San Francisco Bay will be very
different than the ones off of Los
Angeles and off of Seattle and Oregon in
fact if you look at so the red or the
dark here if you're color blind is warm
water the blue or light colors is cold
water and even the 3% of sequences that
assemble across more than one site they
make an absolute distinction between
warm and cold water and some of these
change on a annual basis with weather
other things that affected our sunlight
but in nutrients but we can tell simply
from a sample of seawater looking at the
DNA in that water where that water came
from in the world and for example with
all the ships that come and go from San
Francisco Bay if a tanker comes in off
loads its cargo it fills up its hold
with seawater and will go to its next
port dump all that seawater and take on
new cargo so look at all the ships that
come and go from San Francisco Bay each
day and imagine with a million bacteria
and ten million viruses per milliliter
how these environments are constantly
being challenged and shifted one of the
biggest discoveries we made early on was
that these organisms we discovered in
the ocean had photo receptors molecules
very similar to our own visual pigments
and almost everyone in the top parts of
the ocean have these photoreceptors the
blue segments at the bottom of the slide
is our prior knowledge of photoreceptors
before this expedition and these are
very deep branching a lot of diversity
so instead of being a rare gene family
just affecting our visual acuity it
affects much of a life on the planet we
can line up all these proteins this was
early on when we all
had a couple thousand of them and what
why do this turns out there's a single
amino acid residue that determines the
wavelength of light that these receptors
see so then that allows us to ask some
unique questions do we see any
association with different geographic
regions with the wavelength of light and
we're quite surprised in fact to see
something that makes sense but we nobody
predicted ahead of time for example the
Sargasso Sea it's a deep indigo blue the
organisms that are there the
photoreceptors see blue light you get
into coastal waters where there's a lot
of chlorophyll they see primarily green
light you get into fresh water like the
Panama Canal they see entirely green
light so there's only one letter the
genetic code that is needed to change to
change the wavelength of light by
changing this amino acid residue and
even though there's a large abundance of
organisms traversing these waters the
ones that survive and grow are the ones
that can get their energy directly from
the Sun and last year there was a study
from the Swedish group showing in fact
these organisms grow directly on
sunlight this is not photosynthesis this
is the same biological mechanisms that
you're seeing the slide with right now
you're you're having light hit these
receptors and they transport ions across
the membrane while these micro organisms
that's how they generate their energy in
a low nutrients environment so in fact
instead of low nutrients indicating the
sparsity of life this was some of the
highest density of life anywhere that
we'd seen because they have these
mechanisms of getting energy straight
from sunlight the other thing that we
found is where people thought there was
a single organism we found evidence for
thousands all related in the sense they
have similar sets of genes similar gene
order but hardly a single one each one
of these little bars you see on here
represents nine
base pairs of genetic code one of the
things we can do is take a slice out of
this data anywhere and create trees to
look at the relationships between these
these very closely related organisms
they're color-coded by site so we can
look at things like Atlantic Ocean
versus the Pacific Ocean but the bottom
to me is the most exciting when you look
at recent evolution there's been a
switch between blue and green light go
for these photoreceptors of four
different times so you can see it's such
selective pressure you get a mutation
and you switch from blue to green and
you're in coastal waters obviously
you're gonna thrive if you switch from
blue to green out in the middle of the
ocean you probably won't you can ask
basically any question of this data in a
similar fashion there's in fact a lot of
questions
how much novelty is there with all these
new discoveries that have been doubling
the number of all genes known to science
are they like the photoreceptors just
new members of known gene families or
are we really making new discoveries and
if we're making new discoveries what's
the pace of these discoveries when we
looked at the data set initially we're
quite shocked to find that our database
just between Halifax and the Galapagos
was twice the size of all the public
databases in terms of gene content and
so we did a calculation by comparing all
this data to each other it was about a
million CPU hours and we found out thus
far in the data set there was maybe
50,000 major gene families well we only
have 22 to 23,000 genes maybe 14 or
15,000 gene families so even all of
human biology represents only a subset
of this data but if we look at this as a
as a curve instead of the long now we
have a long tail that basically goes out
approaching infinity right now with new
discoveries and new gene families with
the exception of the animal world so
just to remind people were just an
one part of evolution even though the
tree model doesn't really hold it's
useful for these kinds of diagrams when
we look at our reading the genetic code
in mammals it's basically been saturated
so sequencing another mammalian genome
your favorite pet the species down the
street whatever you're not going to
discover any new genes you might
discover some unique combinations or
spelling of those genes but we pretty
much saturated them a million part of
the tree but if we look at bacteria and
archaea we're in a linear phase of
discovery we don't really know where we
are we just know it's linear our our
thinking is that we're in the earliest
phases of this of just a few percent
that most which means anybody can just
go out to the the bay or go across to
the Pacific take a sample of seawater
and make tens of thousands of species
discoveries millions of gene discoveries
etc we first actually applied these
techniques to the human looking at the
bacteria that are associated with us so
the microbiome is your collection of
microbes not all of you have all these
cavities but you know there's no time
for cavity jealousy or anything but we
can isolate organisms from these
different cavities and for example look
at the person next to you and you know
maybe maybe you see them as having
thousands of species in their mouth
right now or maybe you can taste your
own species on the order of 4 million
genes of foreign species in your in your
mouth in your intestinal tract if you
have those other parts that you have
those as well so we we have more
bacterial cells associated with us than
we have human cells and it turns out
they affect our physiology and some
pretty interesting ways there's a
company
and North Carolina called metabolomics
that's using high-throughput mass
spectrometry to look at all the
chemicals in the bloodstream and they've
worked out that we as a species can make
maybe make around 2,400 chemicals if you
look in the bloodstream of anybody for
example after they've had a meal easily
find about 60% of what's there is made
by our own bodies about 30% are just
chemicals that came out of what we eat
you know so this notion you are what you
eat is partly right but 10% are
bacterial metabolites
so in fact partly we are what we feed
our bacteria and what they give us but
we're dealing at any one time with
hundreds to thousands a foreign
chemicals circulating in our bloodstream
not to mention what we add directly by
taking pharmaceutics or other things and
we have no idea the impact of these on
physiology because in fact we didn't
even know they were there before so
we're looking at the complexity of the
human genome and all the variations
there and what's in our bloodstream and
if we did this test on everybody in this
room we'd get a different answer for
everybody based on what what you ate and
also the uniqueness of the bacteria in
your own guts and your mouth this
affects our chemical milieu this is part
of the environment that affects us we're
also sequencing the air genome so for
example in a room this size sitting here
for an hour you would absorb maybe
10,000 different bacteria and maybe ten
times that in viruses in an hour if you
go outside it's twice that much so
you're actually safer in here right now
depending on who you're sitting next to
again in what they're exhaling and
inhaling so we live in a back
Tyrael milieu going through the water
you're surrounded by bacteria so if
you're out swimming and you swallow a
mouthful of sea water you've just
swallowed millions and millions of
bacteria and viruses the air we breathe
the soil our own skin our own cavities
so we are as much dependent on bacterial
metabolism as human metabolism we've
been collecting all these genes all this
information trying to understand the
complexity and we decided one way to try
and understand the complexity was to try
and mimic it this is standard in
chemistry to prove that you have the
structure that you think you have you
remake that compound we decided to try
and do this
with the genetic code starting with some
pretty simple organisms the second
organism that was sequenced in nineteen
1995 was mycoplasma genitalium that this
is its genome at least it's a depiction
of it very much unlike our genome so it
has a little over 500 genes in contrast
to our 22,000 we have gaps in our
genetic code with no genes that are much
larger than this entire genetic code so
bacterial genomes you can see these bars
represent genes have very little
energetic space this is still the
smallest genome of a self-replicating
organism so it'll grow on its own in the
lab there's smaller genomes but they're
dependent on having a symbiote organism
for its growth so it's not clear whether
they're extension of the viral world or
just truly simple organisms that are
dependent on others and we just ask
simple questions if one cell needs 1,800
genes to live and this one needs 500 is
this actually the minimal set can we
define life in molecular terms based on
the genetic code
and so we set out to try and knock out
genes in this genome to see if we could
get down to a smaller number so every
place you see one of these small
triangles is where a transposon which is
a just a piece of DNA very much like a
small virus that can randomly insert
anywhere in the genetic code then we
select for living cells
so only genes that are not essential can
tolerate transposons going into them so
this is very much a negative map you can
see some genes can take large numbers of
transposons but keep in mind these
experiments only done one gene at a time
and we got to a number of around a
hundred genes that we could knock out
but we doubted whether if we not all 100
out that we could get to a living cell
in fact if we look at a metabolic map of
this simplest of organisms it may look
complex but this is remarkably simple
from looking at any one of cells in the
human body and here's all if all the
different genes that could be knocked
out would knock out a lot of metabolic
pathways probably not resulting in a
living cell so we decided the only way
forward was to actually make chemically
in the lab this chromosome so we could
alter its gene composition and that's
how the whole notion of Synthetic
Genomics
was born with that relatively simple
notion so we started off with two
primary questions can the chemistry
actually permit making these incredibly
large biological molecules accurately in
the lab and if we make it what can you
do with it DNA is an inner chemical can
we actually boot it up into a living
cell that this is comparing the two area
so the red line here is reading the
genetic code and the blue line is our
ability to synthesize DNA it's actually
five orders of magnitude slower right
now for writing the
the code than it is reading it but this
is changing exponentially basically just
over the last few months and I think
writing the genetic code will soon catch
up with our pace of reading that even
though it's still changing now
we thought this would be relatively
simple so there's machines called DNA
synthesizers that can make very short
stretches of DNA called all ago
nucleotides we make pieces that are
about 50 letters long and we thought if
we just make a number of pieces and they
overlap each other that they would just
all go together and we could make a
larger piece of DNA it turns out you can
but the process with these machines for
synthesizing DNA is very inaccurate it's
a degenerative process so the longer you
make the piece of DNA the more errors
there are with it so we set out to do an
experiment trying to make the Phi X 174
genome Phi X 174 for those of you don't
know was is a bacteriophage it's a virus
that kills bacteria particularly coli
and it was one of the first viruses that
was extensively studied in fact it was
the first actual genome of any type that
was done by Fred Sanger we chose this
because in fact its genome is very
intolerant of changes if you change the
genetic code the virus cannot reproduce
so we develop some new techniques for
actually accurately writing the genetic
code where we can repair the errors in
real time as we're making it and for us
even though there had been an attempt by
another group to make the polio virus
which was slightly larger than this it
only had one ten thousandth of the
activity because of all these errors and
making the genetic code we went from the
genetic code in the computer designing
the pieces so that they would go
together appropriately
use this new process for error
correction and we ended up with the PC
DNA exactly the right length and we when
we sequenced it it was exactly what we
had designed and we're trying to make
the exciting part was we took this piece
of DNA and inserted it into the bacteria
e.coli and what had happened was a coli
recognized this as a piece of software
and started making viral particles and
true to form in nature when the viral
particles were released from the cell
they turned around and killed the
bacteria that had made it so this is a
process we see all the time in nature I
was just speaking to oil executives and
I said they clearly understood that
process but but this was pretty exciting
of just taking a piece of DNA and having
it activated
making viral particles so we view this
as the software actually building its
own hardware and this is an important
concept as we're trying to go forward in
this field that even most people that
are working in this area have not truly
grasped the implications of this that we
don't have to design life from scratch
we just have to design the software
appropriately in fact we've gone to
scale this up our plan was to make
pieces that were viral size pieces that
we would then put together to make an
intact chromosome we look for a number
of ways to do this we'd been working on
it for over four years and there's a
process in nature called homologous
recombination this is the paper that you
might have read about that we just
published where we in fact made this
entire chromosome it's the largest
man-made molecule of a defined structure
to print it out one letter at a time at
10 font with no spaces
it takes a 142 pages just
print out the letter code for this
structure its 582 thousand nine hundred
and seventy base pairs or letters of
genetic code and it's over 300 million
molecular weight so the process that we
used was not as simple as just making
pieces that go together but it's close
to that but it started with the right
design and design now is a key part of
biology in fact before we started even
the design phase we had to go back and
resequenced the entire genome because
the standard in 1995 was roughly 1 error
for 10,000 letters of genetic code
nobody thought about when reading the
genetic code even with that seemingly
accurate error code that anybody would
be using those sequences to reproduce
the organisms to actually write the
genetic code and if you're starting with
a genetic code and the computer you can
only make things as accurate as the
information you're starting with so we
went back and sequenced the genome all
over again and found 30 errors which was
the standard for where it should have
been but we know with those 30 errors if
we made this chromosome base on the
initial sequence it would never been
able to be booted up so we start with
this digital information and we design
the pieces thinking that we're now
breaking this 580,000 piece into 50 base
pair segments the 50 base pair segments
have to be designed so they overlap with
their neighbor and we started off by
making pieces on the order of 5 to 7 KB
5 to 7,000 base pairs that each had to
be designed so when they lined up with
their neighbor they would over lap we
designed some other unique elements into
it you might be able to see this on the
top line it shows the places in the
genome where we inserted
Mark's we wanted to absolutely be sure
that we would not fool ourselves or
others by having a contaminant of even
one molecule of DNA from the native
organism and this can be a fun part of
this process so we have a four-letter
genetic code I'm sure most of you know
that we have this triplet code or three
letters of the genetic code code for our
amino acids and we have roughly 20 amino
acids and there's a single letter code
representing each amino acid so we can
write things in the genetic code using
this procedure and we use this in fact
to to label the DNA and the team came up
with some of the authors of the genetic
code and the institution we've read that
people were very disappointed we didn't
put any poetry or other more profound
statements like one small step or
anything like that but what we'll think
about that more carefully for the next
time
so all this went into design started
making these pieces we put for these
five to seven thousand base pair pieces
together to make 24 KB pieces and at
each step we would grow these pieces up
in bacteria e.coli to make large amounts
of the DNA that we then sequence to make
sure it was absolutely accurate because
not only were we trying to make the end
product which we could have done much
faster we were trying to make absolutely
robust methods so we would understand if
errors crept in where they came from
we combined the 24 KB pieces to make a
72 KB pieces in the prior world's record
for the largest piece of DNA made was
around 31,000 it's all these pieces at
72,000 greatly exceeded what had been
done before then we put those together
this looks like a basketball playoff
perhaps to make what we call quarter
molecules and half moly
fuels but what we found as we exceeded
the limits of cloning in bacteria and we
switched to another system we switched
to yeast to put these together and to
grow them up in fact we have always
envisioned that we'd put these pieces
together by this process called
homologous recombination basically cells
in nature do this all the time with
repairing their DNA in fact this
organism dinah Kaka's radiodurans which
is pretty ubiquitous on the planet and
perhaps elsewhere can take 3 million
rads of radiation its chromosomes get
blown apart with a couple of hundred
little pieces then as long as it's in
water over 12 to 24 hours yet remakes
its chromosome exactly as it was before
so here's an accurate picture of it
after 1.75 million rads of radiation I
recommend you not try this at home
because we as a species can only take a
tiny tiny fraction of this amount of
radiation without being killed we can't
do this with our human chromosomes and
so this is a pretty stunning process it
turns out this cell is not unique we
have thousands of species on this planet
that can do this these cells can be
totally desiccated they can be dried out
they can be in a vacuum they can
accumulate this ionizing radiation for a
very long period of time we don't
actually know how long but the
speculation and calculations we've done
is it would certainly fit into the long
now foundation because it's tens of
thousands to millions of years
if the organisms even had slight
shielding in a comet or their material
we know this organism can survive in
outer space it reaches an aqueous
environment and it reassembles its
genetic code and I can start replicating
again so we thought these mechanisms
that we're trying to isolate from this
organism would be great for assembling
the little pieces of the genome to put
it back together again but in fact we
it was even simpler than that it turns
out yeast which is used for making bread
and beer and wine all these good things
we like can do this on its own with
foreign pieces of DNA so while we are
trying to grow up the pieces in yeast we
found that if we design the pieces
correctly and put them in it would
assemble those automatically into the
larger pieces into the intact chromosome
so that's how we ended up with the
entire 580,000 a base pair piece that we
sequenced and it's down to zero errors
this is actually a picture of it
you don't need an electron microscope
because this molecule is so large this
is just looking at over a six second
period so you can actually see it's a
circular piece of DNA and so it was it's
pretty exciting for us to be able to
actually visualize it well how do you
boot up the chromosome you saw with the
virus all we had to do was insert it in
a bacteria and the bacteria can start
reading that software and producing
things we think it's a little bit more
complicated with whole bacterial
chromosomes initially think we thought
we would have to try and remove the
chromosome from a bacterial cell and add
in this new one to replace it it turns
out that's very hard to do so what
you've heard about with mammalian
cloning works very easily in eukaryotes
where there is a defined nucleus that's
easy just to cut out of the cell under a
microscope lift it out and put in a
nucleus from a different organism or a
different cell from the same organism
with bacteria and archaea there is no
nucleus the DNA is part of the cytoplasm
of the cell so we have to use a little
bit more ingenuity to do this and last
year we published what we think is that
the key technique of transplantation
that's pretty stunning in its own right
because we actually by putting in a new
chromosome into a cell
that had a different chromosome in it to
start with we can pletely converted one
species into another so it was a
absolute 100% transformation we use two
closely related mycoplasma species
roughly the same distance apart as we
are two mice we isolated the chromosome
from this my Queenie cell and we wanted
to make sure we could get down to just
naked DNA chromosomes have a lot of
proteins associated with them so we
treated these pretty harshly with
digestive enzymes to digest away all the
proteins and then we added back a few
additional genes to this chromosome one
set of genes the lezzy set for example
will turn the cells of blue so it makes
it easy to identify them and we also
added in a set of selectable markers so
we could select four cells just with
this transplanted chromosome and we put
this chromosome into a species called a
Khafre colum now here's a wonderful
graphic I'm sure you'll appreciate the
sophistication of this we transplanted
the chromosome into the cell in fact we
and thought we would end up with this
situation
a cell with two chromosomes in it we see
this all the time in nature so all these
people that make arguments against
evolution because we know that you can't
just get a point mutation in one piece
of DNA unless it's for the wavelength to
light your photoreceptor sees that
that's going to change into more
complexity what we see in the real world
as we see chromosomes moving around
where you can add a thousand new traits
to a cell in a second cholera for
example most people thought there was no
point in decoding the cholera genome
because it was very closely related to e
coli but when we read the cholera genome
it turns out that didn't have just a
single chromosome
it had two chromosomes and it looked
like this they were very different from
each other obviously it had taken up a
chromosome from another species and
added it to its repertoire well we
didn't want this situation it turns out
the capricolum genome is very unusual in
that it doesn't contain any genes for
restriction enzymes restriction
endonucleases are the molecular scissors
that cut up DNA and it's how cells
protect themselves from this foreign DNA
coming in in fact the chromosome that we
put in did have a restriction enzyme as
soon as it was in the cell it got
expressed and it recognized the original
chromosome is foreign and cut it up into
small pieces and it got digested so we
were left with cells just with the
transplanted chromosome and over a very
short period of time we ended up with
these blue cells that all the
characteristics of these cells were that
what was dictated by the transplanted
chromosome every protein in the cell
changed from that with the original
species into that coded by the my CODIS
chromosome the membrane change
everything changed
we can isolate the DNA and it was only
what we had transplanted in so this is
true identity theft at the ultimate
level and fortunately you know most of
us have mechanisms to protect us against
this and and most cells do with these
restriction enzymes but they give us
very powerful tools to try and do this
in the future so we know we can take a
chromosome we can transplant it we can
completely convert one species into
another so we're in the process of doing
this right now with the synthetically
made chromosome we hope this will happen
very soon these experiments go very
slowly because the cells grow slowly so
it takes about six weeks once you do a
transplant to see whether you have
viable cells but we should be seeing
that whoo
in the very near future that will
complete the the trilogy that we've been
putting together on this although it's
clear now just from the transplant
experiment that we know this will work
and to me it's more of a technicality if
it works with synthetically made DNA
versus DNA out of a cell because it is
the same that sequence is the same but I
think it's still important for the proof
but it transforms us into a new era of
now being Salter cells by simply
rewriting the genetic code so the next
steps in why we I'm gonna walk you
through quickly the some of the reasons
we're doing this and where we're trying
to go but a lot of people when they
think about this and write about it they
think we're redoing Genesis and we're
not this is much more like a new version
of the Cambrian explosion we're
dependent as the the title of this
lecture said on the three and a half
billion years of evolution also in
because we're here as humans because of
that and we're using organisms that have
evolved over a substantial period of
time what's different is we don't have
to redo all that because if we just
write new molecular software we can now
start at that point and go in an
infinite number of directions why do
this one of the reasons is trying to
deal with the future of our species on
this planet over the next forty years
we're going to go from six and a half to
nine billion people that's a huge change
in a short period of time - I try to put
this data in contact for myself and hope
that it leads others to be able to
understand it so I was born in 1946
there's now three people on this planet
for everybody that existed in 1946 so if
you think of having one-third of the
number of people in this room
in 40 years of before people for
everybody that was on the planet in 1946
we're having trouble providing food
clean water energy housing for the six
and a half billion we're gonna have even
more trouble trying to provide it for 9
billion people we're changing our
environment quite dramatically by
burning billions of years of biology in
the form of oil and coal this is now
from 2003 so you know over 5 billion
tons of coal billions of barrels of oil
that we just take out and burn and the
co2 goes into the atmosphere the slide
is out of date it's it needs to be
changed again the third time and a year
this number is now 4.2 billion tons of
co2 that we're adding and stays in the
atmosphere each year that number is
accelerating the ocean sink which is the
largest sink as you can see that can
take hundreds of billions of tons of co2
many people think it's saturated and
deforestation is also contributing as we
try and strip more land to make more
food and fuel everybody has seen this
graph and the study increase in co2 so
what can be done there's a dramatic
revolution that's taking place in the
industrial world equivalent maybe to the
first Industrial Revolution companies
like DuPont which were basically built
on using oil as its raw material have
now had to switch away from using oil
they're switching to sugar which maybe
won't be any more sustainable and we'll
talk about that in a second but they
spent ten years in over a hundred
million dollars altering e-coli to do a
simple reaction to take six carbon sugar
and make
three carbon propane dial molecule I
don't know if you can see those looks
like the large beer kegs those are
actually four 6,000 liter for mentors
that they grow up literally a hundred
tons of this bacteria at a time in a
batch and make propane dial from sugar
with this engineered of bacteria they
can do this a cheaper and faster than
they can with chemical conversion with
their chemist this has certain downfalls
after each batch they have to go bury
that those tons of e.coli in a landfill
because they're not allowed to burn it
but even with all these limitations and
the cost of sugar they claim they're new
polymer that uses this chemical will be
the first multibillion-dollar biotech
product that's not a pharmaceutical so
metabolic engineering is being used my
new company Synthetic Genomics has a
deal with BP to try and use biology deep
in the earth to stop mining coal by
biologically converting that coal into
methane we were quite surprised a mile
down in the earth when we took the first
sample there was more biological
diversity there than we found in the
ocean just a simple microscopic field
was teeming with microorganisms this is
a piece of coal that we have in the
laboratory all those little tiny things
are the bacteria that live off of coal
was a substrate and we have other
bacteria that convert that substrate
right into methane that it's a little
bit dark but maybe you can see the
methane bubbles coming off the coal in
the bottom this doesn't stop taking
carbon out of the ground but it's about
a tenfold improvement over mining coal
and burning it and the Coyle recall
reserves are
extensive enough that this could maybe
get us as a stopgap until there's a new
economy but we've been going in the
wrong direction already in part because
of lobbies in the government corn to
ethanol just is not going to get us
there it's a negative carbon balance
it's been heavily subsidized by all of
us and the numbers are pretty stunning
it looks like a huge amount of ethanol
is being produced and we actually look
at the numbers on the order of six
billion gallons there's now I think a
hundred and sixty plants around the
country six billion gallon sounds like a
lot until you look at what we use so
this is our transportation fuel a
hundred and forty billion gallons of
gasoline forty five billion gallons of
diesel so five to six billion gallons of
ethanol basically does nothing for this
equation
especially when it's produces more co2
than it captures it's competing with
farmland food prices are going up
because of this corn prices have doubled
in the last year so this is just the
wrong experiment taking us very much in
the wrong direction now we're not short
of energy on this planet a hundred and
twenty thousand terra watts of energy
arrives here each day from the Sun if we
could capture that at one percent
efficiency we'd only need about 500
million hectares I've argued this as a
great use of Nevada
and nobody's ever argued whether they
haven't come up with a better
alternative reuse we could just from
sunlight produce energy in fact deserts
in seawater don't compete with food
we're in fact working on I'll show you
in a minute what we're calling a fourth
generation fuel starting with co2 as the
feedstock so if we can start with co2
either from sunlight or in the
methanogenesis pathways we skip all this
of use of farmland for producing fuels
we have two fuels that are pretty close
to going into test production we call
them second and third generation they
both have the downfall of using sugar as
the starting material but they're far
superior to ethanol they don't mix with
water they have very low freezing points
they can just be flash and the blender
they can go through pipelines they have
a much higher energy density to get
people going in a different direction
but the one that we think we'll have in
about 18 months the fourth generation
fuel starts with co2 as a feedstock now
if we can really use co2 as a feedstock
it does several things when you consider
the efforts for co2 sequestration we can
just take piped co2 into reactors
biological reactors and make fuels such
as octane directly from carbon dioxide
either using sunlight as the energy
source or molecular hydrogen you won't
see any energy plans incorporating these
types of ideas we go forward by
extrapolating from the past from linear
ideas of linear thinking there is no
planning for disruptive technologies but
in fact if we're going to change
anything in anybody's lifetime here we
need disruptive technologies
at the Davos meeting this year the
conclusion was 40 years from now biology
and all alternate energy sources will
maybe only make a few percent impact on
using oil and coal because there's so
much vested interest there's a new coal
powered fueled power plant coming online
every day these cost billions of dollars
to build so it's only if there's an
economically viable alternative that
doesn't compete with food that has a
chance to change anything in the near
future and I don't think we want to keep
adding indefinitely co2 to the
atmosphere so we have 10 million genes
in the databases right now we're going
to double that number again this year
from the source or expedition to 20
million these are our design components
the entire electronics industry only had
a few handfuls of design components and
look at the diversity that we have there
we have tens of millions of starting
components that we can build and now
we've built a robot that instead of
making one chromosome for four years we
think we can get up to making thousands
to millions of them a day and in random
combinations so we're calling this new
field combinatorial genomics so just
think of it if we can basically start
with design take these tens of millions
of design components just make the DNA
transform that automatically into yeast
or some other vector and screen for
chemical production for octane
production for antibody production
whatever you screen for will be the
selection that happens it will change
the pace of biology in unimaginable ways
just like I don't think anybody could
imagine in the 1950s this computer
this laptop computer with close to a
terabyte of storage on it doing more
than giant rooms could this is a new
area that's going to be driven by
people's imagination this is sort of a
software that we're working on to make
the new software thinking of this as a
true design phase trying to come up with
new fuels new chemicals and so it's an
exciting time as we try to scale this up
with remarkably small teams this is a
different aspect of Industrial
Revolution and that it doesn't take
armies of thousands in fact that's what
we've done from the beginning with
reading the genetic code the yeast
genome took ten years and a thousand
scientists we reduced that project first
to four months and now to ours and we're
doing the same thing now going in the
other direction it's clear we'll be able
to have a huge dent in the first bullet
here of increasing the understanding of
life because we need to use empirical
methods with the huge data sets that we
have there's not enough scientists to
ask reasonable questions to work out the
biology of what's been discovered to
date but I'm more optimistic but I'm
hoping within 15 to 20 years we can
really have gone a long way for
replacing the petrochemical industry
hopefully biology will be a major source
of energy and bioremediation if we can
capture back co2 and recycle that into
fuel we possibly even start to undo some
of the damage that we've been doing for
the last hundred years and we're also
looking at this in terms of every type
of chemical and looking at making for
example combinatorial antibodies so we
can have instant vaccines for every
variant of the flu virus for example
instead of being a year late like
our again this year this field is
unusual and this is my last slide by the
way it started with us asking the
ethical questions before we did the
first experiments not after we thought
gee whiz we have a lot of potential here
the results of this team at the
University of Pennsylvania published
their review in 1999 they thought we
were proceeding with the right questions
and right technology there was a caveat
about being concerned about biological
warfare the sloan Foundation has just
funded my Institute and MIT for the last
couple of years to do a complete review
of the risk and the benefits they get
published at the end of last year and
there's ongoing discussions a new body
and the federal government got formed
when we published the Phi X 174 genome
got reviewed at the White House they had
to decide whether to try and make our
data and processes secret or published
in the open literature I think it's one
of the few good things that the Bush
administration has done in science as
they went and opted for open publication
but they formed a new branch executive
committee that in has people from every
branch of of the government reviewing
this type of work we've had public
discussion ongoing basically since 1996
on this we're trying to take it one step
at a time but it's about to expend in an
exponential fashion and I think it's
going to be an exciting next 10,000
years thank you very much
okay
for $10,000 whichever comes first
am i alive on the mike great I had a
question before I get into ones from
thank you everybody how do you decide
what to work on next the instrumentation
keeps coming along new tools keep coming
along do they push you into new
opportunity areas or do you work back
from kind of the most important
threshold type needs that you see in
human affairs and work back from them as
to what you do or something else well
it's much more the letter we try to ask
the big questions and we tried to drive
the development of the technology so
we'll have the tools to try and ask some
of those I mean it'd be wonderful now if
we could sequence a human genome for
$1,000 in a few minutes all right I
think we're greedy indeed for that and
driving that forward so the same with
these tools has taken a long time to
develop the synthetic capabilities for
DNA the next stage is now that we have
these robots are going to take this
order of magnitude further so it's the
the ideas and the directions are driving
the technology formation here's a
question from chemistry where are you we
began hey if you were advising a 16 or
20 year old what do you what to study to
be part of the next generation of health
and science what advice would you give
them and what new kinds of careers do
you see coming out well I think one of
the exciting things about what we've
done and maybe why a small group has
been successful is there's we we have
truly multidisciplinary teams some of
the biggest breakthroughs we have have
been in mathematics new algorithm
development new computer computational
approaches obviously the tools that my
friend and colleague ham Smith and Clyde
Hutchinson have developed and in terms
of cloning and manipulating DNA
just straight engineering that there is
no field of science that is not
applicable to this even astronomy my
most exciting new number that comes out
of astronomy is in our own galaxy we
have a hundred thousand earth and
super-earth planets all likely to be in
that sweet zone that could be compatible
with life that's just in our galaxy so
when we think about the ubiquitous
nature of life we're pretty silly to
constantly think it centers around human
existence what's your bet on where their
life is going back and forth between
Earth and Mars and other places well
it's it's definitely being exchanged
where it originated we don't know
there's roughly 200 kilograms of
material exchanged between Earth and
Mars each year if that's not carrying
organisms like Dino caucus and other
things that can easily survive I will be
the most surprised person on this planet
so I know we'll find indications of life
on Mars it could be just because we've
contaminated it but it's possible it's
contaminating earth with a difference
that we only know about 1% of life on
our own planet so we have a ways to go
to understand that well you're as I
understand it's starting to sample
shotgun sequence whole populations in
the air and all the way up to the
stratosphere what do you find as you get
farther and further out from the surface
well we're still working on the the data
and the higher levels but perhaps the
most exciting thing is we're starting to
look at the the gels with space dust
because we have techniques now where we
can amplify from a single molecule of
DNA and there's nothing more indicate of
indicative of life somewhere else than
large macromolecules of DNA so I don't
know if from the gels we'll be able to
find any but we're
gene for the first time but I think just
we've talked about setting up sampling
arrays on the space station
we've contaminated near-earth space
pretty extensively not just with junk
but with microorganisms to an extreme I
think the most exciting story my
brother's here works with NASA sent it
to me I'll probably get him in trouble
for telling this story but next time you
see a shooting star that so in the space
station they used to just pump out the
commodes into space and they realize
they were really contaminating space so
now they pack them into the the waste
material and sustainless steel
containers and launch it back into orbit
and so when you see a shooting star that
that that's that's good [ __ ] from space
man was rusty Schweickart one of the
astronauts he said that when he was in
orbit one of the most beautiful things
you see in orbit is what they call a
urine dump at sunset cuz it sprays out
of course the Sun blasts into it the
earth is dark below and it's quite
burgers they don't do that well unless
they have disease the urine should be
sterile but your should be sterile we
were taught in the army to use it as a
wounds right because it's so sterile you
can wash one didn't you do that Vietnam
no I was in the Navy
we had better techniques
more expensive they always say funny
here's a question from Tyler Emerson
were you against the publication of the
1918 influenza flu genome or for it why
or why not remember bill joy and one of
our other speakers Ray Kurzweil were
Rochas Lee against that yeah it was it
was absolutely the right thing to do and
here's why
looking at that sequence it was not
obvious even though comparing it to my
Institute is one of two major
institutions sequencing most of the
viral isolates from around the world we
could not tell looking at the 1980 flu
sequence why it was so verbal and we
didn't also know how to make the right
vaccines against it so not only
published and it was the right thing I
think the this new committee and the
government approving it to be made
through these synthetic genomic
processes at the CDC it's actually the
first true Jurassic Park scenario
because it was RNA isolated from a
soldier that had died in 1918 and also a
woman that was buried in the permafrost
the RNA still exists in her lungs
our name was sequencing the virus
regenerated in the laboratory we now
know what parts of the virus lead to its
extreme lethal --mess and we can now
screen for that and also new vaccines
are being designed against that so it's
probably going to be one of the most
important breakthroughs in at least flu
virus virology I think killjoy and
others that really worry about these
things you know just take the wrong
approach and you know he's now funding
all kinds of companies to do the same
thing Larry brilliant and google.org and
the guys who are paying close attention
to we're trying to hit off the next
pandemic and you know the the mantra
there is early detection early response
is this stuff going to help early
detection can we do monitoring much
closer to the ground
so that the detection of a pandemic
doesn't begin with dead nurses in a
hospital somewhere reading the genetic
code certainly can it's still amazing
though I mentioned some of the issues
which is doing scientific sampling
around the world there's a number of
countries particularly in Southeast Asia
and even China and Russia to some extent
that don't want the world to know how
much flu they have it's hard to get the
samples out so quite often you hear more
about people dying than getting the
samples so the technology is there you
know if it were set up around the world
it would be easy to get instant
detection the problem is the political
problem that I just mentioned and air
transportation we saw how fast SARS
moved from Singapore to Toronto
fortunately SARS is not anywhere near as
virulent as is the flu virus so we need
to step up the surveillance but I
actually think the synthetic genomic
techniques that we have or what's going
to create vaccines in time we're a year
late and a dollar short right now so if
this was a really virulent virus right
now we'd be in serious difficulty the
vaccine is only what forty percent
effective there's just not time with the
slow processes from even knowing what
the current virus is to getting the
vaccine in time so we need to change
that dramatically so instant virus means
this week or this month or this hour
what I mean it could be done instead
vaccine sorry well the vaccine part
needs to be proven in terms of the
detection we can sequence hundreds to
thousands of isolates in a day if we
have the material that the rate limiting
step is getting the viral isolates from
different countries right now the
vaccine side needs to be tested and they
funded built at a at a scale to see if
it can be done fast enough questions
from Laura from the long
Foundation you've been report telling us
about an incredible richness of really
planetary scale biodiversity here so
should we still give a hoot about the
spotted owl well people care more
apparently about species that they can
see with their own visual acuity then
this extreme diversity that we have on
the invisible world if you look at even
modern textbooks and biology they'll is
diversity is mostly accounting things
that we can see with our own eyes not
things that you need a microscope or a
DNA sequencer to see and detect we have
all kinds of unique varieties of
multicellular birds and mammals that I
think are worth protecting a lot of them
going out of a you know out of existence
pretty quickly with what we as we change
the environment pretty dramatically how
would this technology help that process
of preserving them I'm not sure it's
gonna help the spotted owl but it's
certainly instead of having a canary in
a coal mine we have tens of thousands of
organisms for example had we taken the
samples out of San Francisco Bay before
the oil spill we could have told you
exactly what changed as a result that
oil spill and how long it really took
that to recover in terms of the biology
that's there so that's what we've tried
to do in a global basis as get samples
from the major coral reefs you know
everybody loves the the beautiful sandy
beaches and in the Indian Ocean and
other parts of the world these are a
result of coral reefs dying
just a few degree temperature change
usually ends up killing coral reefs many
people think it's because it's killing
the symbiotic bacteria then can deal
with the temperature changes but what we
now have the first measurements to at
least try try to do that to track these
so it's
it's it could be the ultimate
environmental impact statement to see
what is changing it's probably good for
offshore oil wells to really measure
what's happening there perhaps these
people that think they can get co2
credits by seeding the oceans with iron
most of us think those are some of the
most dangerous experiments being done on
the planet right now see about that why
is that well the indications are it
could cause irreversible damage to the
ocean in anything that has even a slight
risk Evette you know why are we why are
we doing that so a few groups could make
money off of it it's it's just an insane
experiment one wants you to go long and
that expedition to sample what happens
before and after the iron yeah seeding
what would happen so iron is a limiting
nutrient so you spread to a little iron
on you get huge algae broome blooms
mm-hmm then the algae dies off and
presumably sinks down in the ocean and
right and you get more but it's going to
deplete a lot of other nutrients we have
a problem off the west coast
particularly off of Oregon there's these
huge dead zones now no oxygen whatsoever
so fish mammals swim into their the they
basically die from fixation whenever
it's on us by wind not by iron by wind
yeah it's changed the upwelling the
pattern that Ronald Reagan say that no
the scientists in Oregon said that
changing wind will be its own maybe
that'll happen with all this wind
generation lots of people using
antibiotics in their personal life in
the bathroom in the kitchen they head
off all those germs from what you're
saying there's no hope
well not only no hope I mean if the the
worst thing for us as a species is to
try and live in a sterile environment
okay
bacteria are a key part of our
physiology so I think the notion that
you can ever escape bacteria you know of
the tens maybe hundreds of millions of
species on this planet most of them
don't care about us that there's only a
few handfuls that truly infect humans
even the ones that you know share our
bodies most of those are not pathogens
it's not understood at all the
thresholds that change when all of a
sudden bacteria we have associated with
a start causing disease but very few of
them do the trouble with these the
chemical killers killed the whole
spectrum of life and leads to major
mutations that's why we now have you
know I think when you think about new
emerging infections the new completely
antibiotic resistant staph aureus it's
now killed more people in this last year
than HIV in the u.s. it's due just to
over application of antibiotics I'm not
sure whether it's you contribute any of
it to people trying to sterilize their
bathrooms or their hands but certainly
to the widespread use of antibiotics and
in the medical community it's not clear
how rapidly that could spread you know
if you're not near death you don't want
to go to a hospital right now because
you have a higher chance of getting a
staph aureus infection in the hospital
than you do anyplace else so it's is
your technology have a workaround for
that not right now I mean we can try
common or combinatorial production of
new antibiotics with this huge chemical
diversity in the ocean that really has
not been sampled most of the chemicals
that bacteria produce are to kill other
bacteria
right there's some organisms that we
have that actually produced diesel fuel
like materials they actually smell like
diesel fuel using that as an antibiotic
around them so we've probably sampled
you know one millionth of the
antibiotics that are available in the
environment that could be used there is
a complete disincentive in the
pharmaceutical industry to make
antibiotics and antivirals companies
would far rather treat chronic diseases
because they can make a much higher
profit than treating acute diseases so
companies like Eli Lilly completely shut
down their antibiotic Department we
hired some good people out of that but
you know that that's that's helping some
areas but it's we're going the opposite
direction right now when we need new
antivirals and new antibiotics more than
ever so it sounds like one of the career
directions do speak to the earlier
question so you know people are going
through the jungles of the world looking
for wonderful secondary metabolites
that'll be useful against cancer and
things like this it sounds like you're
saying that the oceans may be even a
better place dude I don't know if it's
better but it's a it's largely untapped
the chemical complexity far exceeds what
our chemists could make right now but
again the new biology synthetic biology
gives a chance to replicate and change
that because we can just take the gene
pathways put them in cells and make the
chemicals in the lab and so a number of
people now are thinking about taking
these pathways out of all the organisms
that we've discovered and just making
whole student new sets of molecules that
just greatly exceed the complexity of
what we're currently using because you
can't make them chemically in the lab so
I think there's there's a lot to choose
from
it's a question who's going to do it
who's going to pay for it is there the
incentives and the the ability to even
get stuff out of the market it's it's a
huge hurdle
and I think maybe that's why the the
pharmaceutical industry is going for
much higher profit molecules than
antibiotics and antivirals when you
speak to people in that industry or the
other day when you're speaking to people
in the oil industry
what do you talk to them about you see
this kind of stuff for him what did you
say to the oil guys I told them that the
disruptive technologies were coming and
that they not only need to prepare for
it but contribute to it to help it come
faster so they're part of the solution
not just part of the problem they're
clapping did those guys clap it was a
good response I mean I got out of their
lives you were in vain a moment ago
against ballasts swapping that vast
quantities of ocean bacteria picked up
in one seething part of the world and
released into another seething part of
the world and swapped back and forth you
see this is inherently harmful or or
what it's hard to know because it's been
going on for so many years it's
certainly harmful when you get things
like zebra but mussel larvae and you
know that that's a huge impact in areas
it's not clear whether all these new
species in on the East Coast are from
that or just people emptying out their
aquariums you know there's a certain
selectivity with these organisms based
on things such as sunlight as I gave you
an example of it's not clear what
happens and how much it changes the
environment nobody's measured it before
so whether it's contributing to more
diversity or less diversity we know over
and over again when you get an
imbalanced new viruses appearing in an
environment that weren't there before
new organisms that become dominant
has a pretty catastrophic response look
at all the oyster industries around you
know the Chesapeake Bay used to be a
huge easter industry in San Francisco
Bay used to be there's now viruses that
have wiped out all the oysters maybe it
came from nobody knows where they came
from or even what they are right now
you know it seems like a silly
experiment to do and now most ships
change their ballast water sort of
progressively as they cross oceans they
also dump all their oil and things out
too but it's just me like my fellow
environmentalists should be jamming
ahead and some of the technology you're
talking about - or monitoring for all
these various things doing Diagnostics
like you were able to tell just by
looking at the population of genes in a
particular sample what part of the world
that came from one kind of water it came
from so presumably the same kind of
things will go on with you in cavities
and all the rest of it only be able to
tell who with what their problems are
and all the rest of it well you can also
tell where people have come from it's
been shown for example as we send
soldiers to the desert in a very short
time in the desert all the bugs and
their oral cavity swap out - what's in
that local environment nobody really
knows what impact that has on long-term
health or disease and as this happens
and environments get changed again so
there are certain branches of our
government they're using this
information to try and attract people I
I was asked if I if we could use these
techniques to track bin Laden by finding
his DNA in sewer water I said if it's
not the right guy to do that experiment
trust me there are others who are
and it's done a lot with animals by the
way they do with a scat you can tell
about where they were or what they do
with the you know we have it absolutely
that will increase it but also my fellow
environmentalists are highly dubious
about genetic modification in foods and
continent crops and things like that
what's your view on that well I think
you know it's hard to be right all the
time in each area it's you know we have
a dramatically change in environment
that it's really hard to realize you
know we all like to think life is nice
and simple as we've each of us have
known it and that's why I try to use the
number about the population and trying
to you know personalize it it's a very
different world changing within a single
lifetime and you mentioned that in your
introduction we have to find a way to
cope with the soon to be 9 billion
people you know the the environment is
changing if we don't do it intelligently
people are just gonna do slash and burn
to grow whatever is the most profitable
crop either to provide fuel or food for
their populations that's what we see
happening right now so I I think
environmental it should be the first to
embrace these new technologies not be
lining up to try and stop them it's
gonna take I think a little bit more
thinking on the part of numerous groups
to make that transition well there's a
question and people say ok a 15 and the
tomato is just too weird and it's not
Darwinian and but tomatoes are not
Darwinian in the sense that you know
people fight for eating their natural
Tomatoes you know natural Tomatoes a
small green thing about the size of a
thumb that's not edible it's really
bitter so we've been doing selection of
species on this planet for a long time
and what most people think is natural
has been engineered usually blindly you
know now that we know about the genetic
code in the genome of people
proposal let's just randomly mix these
genomes together from these diverse
species let's see what we get
it's called agriculture it's what
everybody ate before coming here tonight
so I think we need to put it in the
context of what the reality has been
going on in the last century randomly
mixing plant animal bacterial organisms
together so what's so unnatural about a
fish gene and a tomato both those genes
exist in your genome anyway so what are
the things I'm getting from you and from
Hawkins and others working in this field
is that genes themselves are pretty
migratory they wander from genome to
genome and species to species and genus
the genus and all over the place is this
your sense of things well in fact I was
on a recent program with Richard Dawkins
I told them dive begun to think of the
world totally in a gene centric point of
view that genomes are just unique
combinations of those there's basically
an infinite number of combinations we
know a few of them we see the big lens
as I mentioned with our own visual
acuity we have another several million
if not tens of billions to discover on
this planet and if we use them as design
components going forward we can really
harness that information to do something
unique you know the genome structure is
important regulation is very important
when we go from single-cell organisms to
having a hundred trillion cells there's
a lot of key regulation that does go on
we're a long way from mimicking that but
we're using these tools to try and
understand it too you know I think the
sooner we understand it the better
chance we have surviving here you want
to move on up the complexity chain and
do you're curious and bigger animals and
in terms of I think it's a sense you
know as you know when you talk about the
long now features many people have
argued humans have two chances for
survival let's find another planet
go contaminate and move there or let's
engineer humans to survive and higher
co2 concentrations or altered biology so
we can survive on the mess we're making
here those are the two long-term current
views but many people hold for Humanity
I'd like to think we have a third
alternative of trying to change the
environment before we get to that point
but certainly engineering if youth
design theory to plants you just design
a plant for a specific purpose that'll
live in an arid environment need very
little water maybe even live off of salt
water and produce useful feedstocks for
fuels or food that could be a pretty
nice thing design and disease resistance
the kind of replication you want etc you
know we are living machines we are
design about and I think it will be in
the time course that your foundation
looks at it will be inevitable to
engineer humans great two more questions
one from JD Ross Lahey you use a lot of
computer metaphors inter explanations
booted up software hardware what do you
see is the main similarities and the
main differences between computer
programs and organisms well we don't
have too many computers yet that can
build their own hardware from their
software's I think dynamic you know some
people are hoping to get there you know
we're part way that in some assembly
lines biological systems can do this
very dynamically you can actually build
the computer from the software I think
that's it's a it's an important
difference at least for now
I think microorganisms for example can
produce things on scale copies of
themselves on scale that can be
used for industrial purposes when you
look at landfills obviously we're
producing computers on some sort of
scale but not necessarily to solve
directly manufacturing problems computer
can process information the biological
software the biological computer can
produce
food fuel chemicals who knows what we
you know plastics can bring produced
biologically off of plants I think as we
start down this road even coming back to
talk a decade from now and looking at
all the things that people are trying to
do through biological engineering will
be pretty dramatic if you looked a
thousand years from now we probably
wouldn't recognize anything's because it
could all be biological machines
including computers but I guess there's
that another comparison that's often
made between computer technology and
biotechnology is the peace of self
accelerations ABS on so Moore's Law
doubling its capability every year in
Africa so people like Rob Carlson say
that the pace of advance and
biotechnology right now is faster than
that one is that your sense of things
and there's a continuing to accelerate
and does that s-curve ever level offer
is it pretty indefinite well I had a fun
discussion with Gordon Moore because I
argued that DNA sequencing reading and
genetic Oh biology was changing faster
than Moore's law right but he said
you're dependent on computers so Moore's
law always Trump's bunters law until we
get bio computers and then that Trump's
lasso or quantum computers or something
I I think it's it's sort of like the
stages of evolution of you know we have
this three and a half billion years
behind us it's not gonna take you know
even possibly decades
they make what happened over billions of
years and go dramatically further so I
think we're we're at a sharp turning
point in biological systems as we can go
just straight from digital code to
biological code and harness that power
to do new things I think that's gonna
totally change the future shape of
humanity hopefully the future existence
of humanity but I think it's gonna be a
very sharp divide from the previous
three and a half billion years well it
cervezas the question why you talk to
audiences we're just telling me
backstage you give about 150 talks a
year that's quite a lot for a still very
busy science and so every time you're
out doing this you're not in the lab
you're not raising another round of
money or night or to apply another round
you're not doing the research you might
want to be doing catching up with other
people's work well I put this much time
into basically public discourse well
we've seen over and over again new ideas
new disruptive technologies really being
either killed or set back dramatically I
think Jim you your environmental friends
talking about GMOs that are certainly
set back a lot of an agricultural
revolution you know the whole thing was
handled badly all the way around in
terms of government regulation there
wasn't enough of it there wasn't enough
scientific testing to really work out
what happened and in a lot of these
genes as we talked about do hop around
in the environment and they can move
there was enough thought given to that
but several years ago I was meeting with
the head of the German Green Party and I
said when you put that you're either for
or against biotechnology or for or
against GMOs I'll always come down on
the fore side but if you try to have an
intelligent discussion about how it
should be done it should have been done
very differently with a lot more testing
a lot more thought than a lot more
regulation I think as we go into a much
more dramatic phase of actually
designing biology originally from
scratch possibly as it scales up if the
public is not thinking about it if the
government's not thinking about it in
the lines of what it can do and what it
can't do this whole area get killed off
just as fast as GMOs have or setback
substantially I would like as I argued
to Davos that you know we need to try
and change something in the next 40
years in these arguments that that's
going to be almost impossible to change
anything
the only hope there is for disruptive
technology I see biology as one of the
furies it really has a chance to be a
disruptive technology and the fuel
production co2 capture we don't want
people to be scared away for the same
reason that French farmers tried to shut
down GMOs either because of an economic
argument so we're seeing a little bit of
an economic argument with the corn to
ethanol of being you know appropriately
attacked but people want to throw out
all biofuels now because corn to
ethanol's allows the experiment right
you know these are dangerous times that
I think technologies have to be part of
people's repertoire it is no longer an
option for saying for society not to be
dependent on high ends
we if we're going to survive as a
species long-term if we're gonna fear
foundation's going to exist in ten
thousand or a million years base me well
you know we have to do something very
different very soon well it's okay
you're talking to lots of audiences
large one here even larger one on the
other side of the television camera so
it looks like you're looking for
understanding in these audiences you're
looking for kind of permission and even
encouragement from these audiences with
computer technology the technology went
totally Democratic anybody can do it
I assume once you have the
thousand-dollar genome and other tools
like that which are fast cheap they will
also be fast to keep an out of control
and so there'll be biotech hackers and
there will be people in involved in
national security who will freak out
that prospect probably with reason kill
Joey will freak out and recruits whoa oh
you better stop funding on ya won't know
what to do about that thing but it's
coming
so garage biotech threat Menace promise
delight what is it well that there are
some people in in these this new broad
field of synthetic biology not Synthetic
Genomics but synthetic biology that are
encouraging biohacking then into some
extent that that is inevitable that the
techniques and tools require a little
bit more sophistication for building
genomes and species but it will become
largely democratic we want everybody to
have their genome sequenced
understanding that is the only way we're
gonna lower health care costs getting
into preventive medicine you know that
firsthand wipes in the business that's
right so she's been pushing this longer
than than most the world slowly catching
up with her
so we want to get to that that phase in
medicine we want people to think in
terms of DNA what it means and what it
doesn't mean okay so you only want their
permission you want their cheek swabs
well I don't personally want them but
but there's what do you do you know and
once that's out there then that database
of humanity is baseline data it's all
these things you've been talking about
understanding who we are what's going on
right what we're supposed to do with
that knowledge and I think that there'll
be two surprises on the human side I
think we'll be surprised and I've
written that with John Brockman's edge
that we'll be surprised how much of a
genetic species we are and ways that
mean that most if not all human
characteristics and traits have a
genetic component and you know most
parents realize this they see their kids
and realize that they have unique
personalities from day one they don't
want to acknowledge necessarily that's
due to genetics depending on their
parents and depending on the personality
but we are very genetic organisms but
all at the same time we are very plastic
species meaning we're very moldable
depending on our environment so to some
extent knowing what you're at risk for
will help with preventive medicine and
disease in terms of the Sociology I
think it probably won't matter that much
because the environment is so important
for us but we will find out and we'll
find out on a broad scale what I'm
worried about with a lot of the the
startup companies that are measuring
incomplete information is that we'll
just get wrong answers for quite a while
before we have the complete information
but eventually science Trump's ignorance
depends on the heart the equation is you
know the internet could help or hurt
with that issue well we should call it
an evening keep the science coming and
we'll keep internetting at your science
and help every way we can they
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you